Speaker 1: Let's go next to Johnny from Boston.
Johnny, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hey, David.
Speaker 6: On a question in regards to the
trans women in bathroom legislations, I've
been going around and sure, quite frankly,
I don't feel like they really are honest with
the language because I feel like they're playing
on the prejudices of voters and I'm perhaps
maybe ignorance of what trans people are.
Do you think that's done willingly or do you
think that there are people who really don't
understand what like trans issues and trans
rights are?
Speaker 4: Well, give.
Speaker 1: Me what do you what do you mean?
What's the language that you that's in the
bills that you think doesn't consider the
reality of trans votes?
Speaker 6: So they talk more about like, look,
we're going to have trans women in bathrooms
and then it's like we're going to go, you're
gonna only have the people in the bathroom
of their biological sex assigned at birth.
However, they're not thinking of the reality
is that that means trans men who look and
present as men are going to end up in women's
bathroom.
Yeah.
If they go like they don't feel like they're
thinking this out.
Speaker 1: You're absolutely right.
And so what you're basically what you're pointing
out is that if you just make a rule that basically
says you've got to go in the bathroom that
matches your biological sex at birth, there
are plenty of trans women now who they to
the Ava I'm trying to use you know, careful
but respectful language to the average person.
You see these individuals and you go, that's
a woman.
You you would have no particular reason to
say that's not actually a woman.
As I see it, if they are forced to go to the
men's room, it's going to be just as confusing
of a situation.
You can also take take the opposite and talk
about trans men as well.
So you're completely correct.
And the issue is they don't really care about
that.
They just care about having what they see
as the morally and politically correct rule
that goes along with their preexisting worldview.
They don't care about the practicality or
reality of it.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
And then it's and I and I also am frustrated
with people who are GP's who say that they're
trans allies and don't speak up on it like
that.
That's hot garbage.
Yeah.
They should that like I see people like Meghan
McCain not say a damn thing about it, but
oh is that right to be.
And she claims to be a like an LGBT ally go
you know t means trans right use your platform.
Speaker 1: A lot of people are, you know,
unfair for a lot of people.
Being an LGBT ally means they have one lesbian
friend, you know?
Speaker 6: Right.
Or they want to watch Drag Race, like, literally.
Speaker 1: Right.
Very well said, Johnny.
Thank you.
Speaker 6: Yeah, thanks.
Was it?
Speaker 1: There's Gianni in Boston.
Great to hear from you, as always.
Let's go next to.
Oh, I don't know.
There's a lot of a lot of people a lot of
interesting folks waiting today.
Why don't we go to Ruminate in Kentucky as
ruminate your first or last name.
Speaker 5: Is just my stage name.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Speaker 5: David Mann, I appreciate you taking
the call.
Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Well, I can hear you beautifully.
Speaker 5: Perfect.
So I'm a big fan of the show.
I was introduced to you during the pandemic
and you and like Brian Tyler Cohen and a bunch
of others, you helped get me through it.
So I appreciate, you know, all that you do.
I do have a specific question about rhetoric,
moderating rhetoric.
So, you know, friends of yours like Destiny,
who I'm also a fan of, and even your new correspondent,
Luke Beesley, who did a great job at Texas.
He did.
They are fans of or they seem to be proponents
of moderating rhetoric that leftist, even
progressive leftists in terms of their public
outreach should moderate their rhetoric, even
though the GOP seems to be increasingly radical,
increasingly aggressive.
And there's this this dispute in the leftist
community.
Should we be more aggressive?
Should we try to appeal more across the aisle?
And I'm curious what you think about it.
Speaker 1: Well, let me ask, what do you what?
Why do you say that?
Our correspondent Luke seems to favor moderating
rhetoric.
What gave you that impression?
Speaker 5: He did a discussion with Weisz
or Walsh yesterday.
Was a really good conversation.
Speaker 1: Basically did?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Speaker 1: How did they get in touch?
That's fascinating.
I didn't know they talked to each other.
Speaker 5: I mean, your name carries weight,
man.
He's he's a Deepak correspondent.
That's like that's political royalty.
Speaker 1: Oh, I'm going to have to watch
that.
Okay.
And so he said he was a fan of moderating
rhetoric.
Speaker 5: Yeah.
Because I mean, I'm sure you're familiar enough
with Bosh, know that, you know, which I'm
a fan of his as well.
But he definitely takes a more aggressive
route with respect to rhetoric.
He thinks that the Republican Party as an
institution, its leadership is evil, they're
morally wicked.
And so he feels that there should be a greater
condemnation of the GOP by leftists, by Democrats,
by progressive, by just bog standard liberals.
Yeah.
And Luke's position was probably like, Hey,
man, I think that that's going to scare people
away.
And I see both sides of it.
But I also feel this is the loop aired more
closely on the side of moderate rhetoric.
I am is a moderate person, and yet it doesn't
seem to be doing him any favors with independents
and centrists and whatnot.
So that's why I wanted your take on I mean,
you you in your videos, you are very candid
that the Republican Party and the Democratic
Party, though flawed, are not comparable.
The Democrat, the Republicans are infinitely
worse as a institution.
Yeah.
Do you think that leftists should be more
emphatic about that?
Like, no, this this notion of a bipartisan
future and that we need a strong Republican
Party like Speaker Pelosi says that that's
just crap and we've got to get more radical
in our rhetoric.
Speaker 1: So here's my view.
I don't think that it should be one thing
or the other for contrived reasons of optics
or strategy.
I think that we should just be really clear
about calling things as I see them.
So I can't speak for anybody else's perspective.
My perspective is I'm not going to artificially
use milder or more extreme rhetoric just for
the reason of how it will look.
I'm going to describe things in the way that
I think they are and with the language that
I think is most appropriate.
And when I'm talking about radical, repugnant,
lunatic Trumpists, that's what I'll call them.
I won't say anything that's moderate, more
moderate or more extreme than than what I
see them as being.
I'm open to other people saying, no, the strategy
should be to use either more moderate or radical
rhetoric for this reason or for that reason.
My approach and people can tell me it doesn't
work or it's wrong is I just call things and
describe things as they are with the language
that feels accurate.
Speaker 5: Right.
Fair enough.
And then one last thing I just want to say.
I think that you are you're probably your
standout quality on your show is you are a
superb interviewer.
So I was going back and watching your interviews
with Tim Poole and Michael Knowles and Sam
Harris and that recent one, trigonometry.
Yeah.
My guess my last question is, do you do right
wingers or more centrist figures like Sam
Harris isn't a right winger, but he is certainly
more centrist, I think, than many others.
Do they avoid interviews with you or like
do you reach out to people often to have those
sorts of incisive Tuesdays?
And do they do they take you up on the offer?
Speaker 1: It's a mix.
We reach out to tons of people all the time
and there is no rule.
You know, Sam Harris has previously accepted
requests from us, but for a year and a half,
I've been trying to get him back on and he
has not accepted.
So I, I, there's no hard and fast rule, but
I'm obviously open to talking to all sorts
of people.
Speaker 5: Yeah, well, I appreciate it, David.
Thanks.
And keep doing what you're doing, man.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much.
Appreciate the call.
I mean, I have to check out that Vouch and
Luke Beasley appearance.
That sounds pretty interesting